all right let me start with the Derrick
Rose being dealt here I know we like to
do winners and losers just give me the
philosophy behind what the Knicks were
trying to do or hoping to do here well
there are a couple things one the Knicks
want to be players in free agency in
2017 so in in making this deal they do
get out from under the last three years
of Robin Lopez contract and Lopez has
become expendable to the Knicks in large
part because the belief is that
eventually kristaps porzingis is going
to be a center so if you move for zynga
to the five and if he's playing 35
minutes per game you don't really have a
need for a player like Lopez is a good
player but not someone that's that's
really necessary you're trying to get
some cap space there and Derrick Rose
look is an improvement over over Jose
Calderon might help them get into the
playoffs this year it's a worthy flyer
to take down on a player that you know
showed signs he was getting healthy last
year still is not a great shooter but it
could potentially be a you know top 15
point guard once again yeah but we can't
keep saying Derrick Rose's an upgrade
over Jose Calderon I mean he's an
upgrade their ma 99% of the guards are
an upgrade over Jose Calderon if you
traded Derek to get Derrick Rose and you
had a Jose Calderon in your back court I
blame management so yeah I don't go boy
it's an upgrade over Jose Calderon yes
that's not hard to do but you also take
on Derrick Rose and that salary as well
so I don't give any credit salary they
take on the salary be taken on for one
year yeah and it's a low-risk
proposition the key to the Nixon and in
talking to people over there in the
aftermath of the trade the key to the
Knicks is what they do now I mean it
Derrick Rose Carmelo Anthony and in
Christa's porzingis does not get them
into the playoffs it just doesn't not
nice turn conference which has gotten
better at the bottom half what they do
now is important they have got to add
pieces that complement these guys they
need a facilitating to guard I've been
writing for a couple of months now that
Evan Turner is
is high on their list because he is that
kind of play maker who could fit in
alongside and start moving the ball a
little bit they need a defensive-minded
Center someone like Joakim Noah why they
would be a terrific fit with that group
they do not need I know you mentioned
this briefly early in the show Dwight
Howard no God no under no sir Dwight
Howard is running as far as humanly
possible from James Harden who wouldn't
pass him the ball why would Dwight
Howard go to New York and play with two
guys who won't pass him the ball it that
just not going to happen in New York
what mclovin well you got to remember
Jose Calderon was on that Spanish
Olympic team and the Maddox told us that
no one can stop him Wow oh of course he
thinks it's a blow for the next to lose
them Wow hey how's how's Jacob Patil
doing there bharathi oh you almost got
his name a quarter right yakap yakap
bottle spanish stack i had a few other
things okay USA all right so Dwight
Howard ends up in like Charlotte or
Atlanta or or land I don't think I know
I look I think the market for Dwight
Howard is going to be robust now twice
gotta figure out and it's going to take
him a few days to a week that the max
level contract market forum it just
isn't there but once he realizes that
and the salary demands come down a
little bit they're going to be you know
half doesn't do a dozen teams that are
really interested in you mentioned
Charlotte I'm not i've heard mixed
things out of there about their interest
Atlanta certainly could be in the mix
the Milwaukee tried to trade for him at
the deadline last year portly could
certainly use a five-man like Howard
there'll be a bunch of teams willing to
line up and give Dwight I don't know 15
to 18 million dollars per year in a
four-year deal I don't think that that
Dwight is radioactive by any stretch I
think the expectations then that that we
have for Dwight and the criticism we
heap on Dwight is a little bit unfair
for a player of his caliber no he's not
a carry a team type of player anymore
but you put him as a second option or
the third option on a team with
aspirations to win something I think he
can be extremely effective as long as he
is comfortable accepting that role of
being a second or third that's that's
been the problem I think that he still
looked at himself as he was a superstar
and he's not potential to still be very
good but not a superstar there there's
got to be something in between for
Dwight from the superstar but he once
was to the afterthought that he was last
year with the Rockets I mean I think he
attempted like eight and a half shots
per game last year like Dwight shouldn't
do that you should be getting in the
ball you know for 12 to 15 shots per
game something in that neighborhood if
he can accept that range I think that
Dwight could still be a terrific player
you want to be following the vertical on
yahoo sports with Chris Mannix and
Adrian will generale ski their draft
date coverage draft night coverage
better than anybody else here's our poll
question Ben Simmons will be great good
average I think if you're if you're
putting it there I think he becomes
great I do I think his talent is you
remember right after the the season
ended there was mock drafts out there
putting Brandon Ingram first I kinda
laughed at that because there's a
there's a gap and it's a significant gap
in talent between Ben Simmons and
Brandon in here dad Allegra Marcin uh no
I just you know you look at the size and
I spent some time in upstate New York
with him a couple of weeks back and it's
not just the the skinny legs Dan it's
the skinny hips he's like a size 28
waist and and when you see guys that are
um better skinny with skinny legs
usually have bigger hips that indicates
they can fill out a little bit and get
stronger with that lower body I'm a
little concerned about what he looks
like it but the concerns I have for Ben
Simmons are generic you know every
freshman coming out concerns me know he
can't shoot and but nobody can shoot
when they come out of college really
except the the specialist and he had
some problems with assertiveness last
year I mean that sounds a lot like what
LeBron was in his first couple of years
in the NBA I think those those things
are very easy to overcome and I think
once he gets the NBA and works with NBA
coaches he is going to accelerate
quickly and become a star very quickly
all right rapid fire here Dirk
Nowitzki's next stop is Dallas no
question they'll give him a huge deal
and at some point is going to become a
part owner of that franchise Kevin
rance next stop one year deal Oklahoma
City ties himself to Russell Westbrook
in some ways but he'll he'll he'll turn
down the the idea of Golden State and
he'll turn down aggressive off from
Boston Kevin love's next move somewhere
other than Cleveland um I don't I don't
know how you end that season and think
the Kevin Love is going to be a helpful
to you in beating Golden State next year
everything that the Cavs do dan has got
to be predicated on how do we be golden
State because you have to think that uh
the war is going to be back next year
the war is not back its Oklahoma City
which has a guy that stood Serge Ibaka
can stretch the floor if they're not
back it's San Antonio in San Antonio
targeted Kevin Love in the two
regular-season games they played against
them last season I think if the
Cavaliers can find a deal that Nets them
some kind of defensive minded to guard
or some kind of and or some kind of
three four men who could slide between
positions and small lineup they'll look
to make a deal for Kevin Love the next
stop for LeBron James Cleveland at least
for one more year I mean I I'm his his
language is always interesting how he
choose even he doesn't say I'm back baby
and I'm here to stay he says I can't see
myself going anywhere else there's
always wiggle room with LeBron James but
the summer of 2017 is the most
interesting one he's already got
Cleveland the championship if he gets
them another one even if he doesn't
really he can say you know I got what do
you want to want to get I'm gonna go
somewhere else and that summer is when
Chris Paul is going to be a free agent
and he can find a way to play with Chris
Paul to play with Dwyane Wade maybe to
play with Carmelo to the potential for
biggest bust tonight is now you're gonna
save this and clip this and I'm gonna
get screwed three years from now arm
biggest bust I'm gonna say dragon vendor
I just you know that we keep getting
last year nobody wanted kristaps
porzingis now everyone's looking for the
next kristaps porzingis and porzingis in
bender don't share a lot in common
porzingis is a five a defensive player
you know versatile at seven foot three
benders good but I think the
expectations on him our way to i'm not
saying is young vessel
he who was a total disaster but if he
wind up going to the top five I think
he'd be disappointing what mclovin its
drag on bender I think I have fun
tonight I'm glad by the way then you you
talk to Richard Jefferson not a retired
guy I tried to do it in the immediate
aftermath of the game the other night
that was insane yeah it's just a little
thing of me giving back to Cleveland you
know it's not going to show up in the
box score but well he you know what I
think though Dan and he shouldn't even
go back to Cleveland Richard Jefferson
is you know when you look at the get to
salaries is your guys like Richard
Jefferson are going to be signed to
one-year deals that are ridiculous
because teams need to make that
exorbitant salary cap floor which is
like 70 plus million dollars so to make
that salary cap floor and to preserve
their cap space for the big summer 2017
when LeBron could be out there Russell
Westbrook Chris Paul all these guys to
do that you've got to sign players like
Richard Jefferson so don't be shocked if
some team out there offers RJ like a one
year 12 and a half million dollar deal
thank you Chris you got it damn that's
Chris Mannix Yahoo's the vertical
they'll have their NBA draft day and
draft night coverage the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience